what was your relationship like with
vaughn man
i'm a boy for sure like i don't really
violent people right
he was one of the ones i buy but for
real like outside of music
definitely you know what i'm saying we
talk about everything together
i'm a boy for sure how did you guys
initially link up like what was that
it's so crazy bro
i ain't even know who he was at first
mm-hmm i had i had to show up or dirk
dirk no no i was saying tink and all
them
like virginia so i'm walking past him
like i said i wouldn't even
like feminism walking past him like
what's up ace but i ain't really him i
just walked right past right right
you know everybody around me like
kissing all them boy they like whatever
like whatever that's why i go back over
there you know what i'm saying my
brother fought with y'all foreign
we said a few words at that night but
not too much
not to be like friends but we're just
cool like
over time over that time we just like
just talking like you know i'm saying
not too much of sliding up on you
like and one day he got on he got on the
uh and come on
and i came today like pull up i pulled
up on from that day
it was something probably right before
that too that means like i'm gonna pull
up tyson but it was like from that day
right there it was just over it like
that's my boy
and just went for i was just out for
like five six hours oh wow
just vibing you're gonna anchor them on
the two so you can go
you can't move around i'm just every
time not every time i came to the air
just with him
yeah yeah like bro come today come today
and then he'd come well i'm at them
you know what i'm saying to went from
miami whatever what was going
we're just linking our airtime what was
it like uh you know obviously
finding out you know about his loss man
it was it was you know it was
unfortunate because we actually got
we saw what happened there's video of it
you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] up i ain't gonna lie and i ain't
been [ __ ] like that [ __ ] up like
that
for i mean you've been through the whole
time yeah you've had
your brothers you know what i mean like
yeah so yeah and she ain't gonna afford
me because my foot will
be feeling like every time i [ __ ] with
somebody some [ __ ] like that like yeah
or something [ __ ] like that happen so
i'd be trying to buy that one already be
getting into
like relationships you said uh that you
were not around enough people to catch
covet
so i'm assuming you stay up out the way
exactly
fond died beefing with a guy
not even in his own city with another
guy who
ain't from his city either some real rap
[ __ ] really some internet [ __ ] right
and like did that kind of like does that
kind of like
motivate you to move different when you
when you saw what happened to him
because this
you know that's just crazy to think he
died in atlanta he's from chicago
beefing with the dude from baton rouge
like it's
it's you know what i'm saying it's like
it's so unknown it's just a wildest [ __ ]
to me bro like oh that's just
crazy though no i'm saying so
but does that kind of like motivate you
just kind of just stay out the way like
y'all yeah you hitting the club are you
staying home like
go to club you just stay home i don't
know there's no reason why you're
getting paid i ain't going away yeah you
go get your bag otherwise you you at the
credit show
i'll be vibing i'll be i'll be i'll be
chilling i don't really like
i don't even like dealing with people i
don't even be one kind of recording
songs
i never even record a song in the studio
other rappers except like vaughn and
jd young who i just did something with
lil yachty
nice that's probably the only people
i've ever been in the studio with